music you can dance to it sing with it
fall love to it unless you're a Dalek of
course then it's just noise
[Music]
so tribute time in a way because Murray
gold is leaving Doctor Who and I think
ultimately that's probably a good thing
I mean he's he's been great I love the
dark the Doctor Who music I own not
every series soundtrack but a lot of
them and there's some amazing stuff on
there but at the same time I think it's
probably a good time for some fresh
blood it's probably a good time for a
new approach a new sound and so as much
as I love Murray gold's work I'm very
interested to see what comes next but he
is out so I'm gonna do something that I
wasn't sure I was ever gonna do because
I get very iffy about using music clips
in my videos because it's liable to get
flagged for copyright or whatever and
that is probably still gonna happen but
I'd be remiss if I didn't do this
because the man deserves it and so here
we go with my picks for the 10 best
Murray gold tracks from Doctor Who this
was really hard I could have made a
fifty I could have made a twenty super
easy and there's so many tracks that I
love that didn't quite make the list
this is Gallifrey the Cybermen the lone
Dalek valley DGM the new doctor words
win wars just so many great tracks that
didn't quite make the cut so let's start
and get to the ones that did starting
with number 10 melody pond
[Music]
I Don this music when I discussed the
episode a good man goes to war and the
fact that the music that comes in at the
end of this episode when we get the
reveal about River Song about who she is
about what her what that name actually
means to me is sold and solidified by
that music by that haunting vocal that
would that air of mystery and yet
hopefulness to it does so much to sell
this moment that maybe not everybody
bought into I did and I think the music
is a big part of it and it's a terrific
track that like I said it just weaves
this mix of mystery and hope together
and that's tricky because mysterious
sounding music tends to lean more in the
kind of creepy spooky area so to have a
sense of mystery but also have a just
this sense of things are gonna be okay
and this is this is good to have both
those things come across in the music at
the same time that's that is dang
impressive number nine the blink sweet
[Music]
so one of the more low-key tracks that
Marigold ever did I think some people
criticized his music as being overly
bombastic and there's some validity to
that although at times I think I would
blame more the the choices for where to
place his music as opposed to what he
actually wrote because some things just
got excessively overused in place and in
put in places that didn't make sense but
this is one of his more low-key
offerings and it sets the mood for one
of the best episodes of Doctor Who
modern era Doctor Who so well it sets
that tone it maintains that tone the
melancholy the sadness but the creeping
sense that we're being watched right now
and I'm not sure from where but we're
definitely not alone and again
communicating that kind of stuff through
music in a way that really did add so
much to the episode it's just slow and
somber but slightly unsettling it's it's
a really effective track number eight
the doctors theme
[Music]
now what I talked about the episode
twice upon a time and I mentioned this
the I I personally called it
specifically the ninth doctors theme
technically it is the doctor seemed
foreign theme for nine and ten
but there's there are other tracks that
in my mind became more like tens
signiture sort of theme even though they
weren't called that so in my mind I
still think of this as nines theme and
it has that air of mystery that Marie
gold is good at bringing when he wants
to
and again just those those little hints
of the vocals of of this haunting vocal
sound which he he does tend to bring him
when he has vocalists take part in these
tracks and there's also a sense of
loneliness of loss to it which hey again
I know it was around four done and two
but energy as well but for Eccleston
especially was perfect
it told you so much about him as a
character and just enhanced a great
performance that we were already getting
from a terrific actor in this part it's
a really effective theme number seven
one that people may not be expecting my
angel put the devil in me
yet the devil
we were real specific the soundtrack
version not the one not the version that
Tallulah sings in the Daleks in
Manhattan the episode proper the studio
recording of this song I love this song
and Mariko did write it I checked I made
certain that like I didn't just
attribute it to him because it was on
the soundtrack he did actually compose
this right yes he did it's on the list I
I have a weird relationship with this
sort of 30s you know jazzy burlesque II
kind of music which is that I love
things that evoke it I don't love a ton
of the authentic music from the time
though it's weird but this is the kind
of thing that I love because it evokes
that era and that sound in that sense of
show and fun so well with these terrific
vocals and these fun lyrics and I
honestly I I don't know how many times
I've listened to this song
it's so much dang fun I've done
performance numbers to this songs I love
it that much I gotta bring it back I
gotta do that again
number six all the strange creatures
[Music]
now this one kind of Adam i
understanding originally written for the
promo going into season three and in my
mind this is the track that effectively
became tenants theme and I know it's
officially it's not but I feel like it
got used in the show as if it was and I
think it works for that it's more a
sense of adventure
as opposed to you know sort of the
mystery melancholy of the theme that had
been a holdover from Eccleston's time
this has a sense of you know here comes
the threat here we go and you know it
has that mix of intensity and kind of
fighting the good fight and however
music is able to exemplify that this is
a one of his kind of bombastic tracks
but I think it really works here and and
especially because it does have moments
where it eases back a little bit and
then it kicks in again it's just yeah
this works really well for me
number five doomsday
[Music]
this was another one that people should
have seen coming if you saw some of my
previous lists on Doctor Who episodes
because I've talked before about
doomsday and the music really really
does a lot to sell the sadness of rose
being trapped in another dimension and
the way it kicks in and again the those
haunting vocals and but also the the
strings coming in with the sense of
longing as she's on one side of a wall
and he's on the other and you just you
look at that and you think they should
be able to break through that wall and
see each other but they they can't they
won't be able to and the music
underscores all of that perfectly her
desperate banging on the wall his just
leaning against it knowing that he's not
gonna see her again
and the music just pourings it on home
completely number four Amy and the
TARDIS
[Music]
now I knew I was gonna have some version
of I am the doctor on here somewhere
because that I kind of mentioned before
things being overused and used in places
where they didn't necessarily work and I
really think that happened - I am the
doctor which is a very good track for
the record I enjoy it I even enjoy a lot
of the variants of it
I mentioned words win wars you know as
one that I I considered putting on here
but I didn't want this list to be taken
up with variations of I am the doctor I
wanted there to only be one entry on
here that included that theme very young
noticeably and the reason I picked this
one over the actual track of I am the
doctor is there's something about the
way it eases in and the slowness and the
quietness and the sort of childlike of
how it starts out with this very just
light and almost kind of tinkling kind
of sound to it that goes with a me first
stepping in and then when it's time to
actually get that thing going and take
an adventure somewhere it kicks up and
into I am the doctor and there's
something about the transition of those
things from Amy's theme into I'm the
doctor put together in this one track
and the way they transition and
complement each other that I think
elevates both to more than what they are
on their own number three a good man
[Music]
so yeah I basically included what woody
there are the official or what I
consider to be the themes of all the
doctors of the modern era and I like
Capaldi's best I think it it strikes the
right balance of strength and you know
retaining a bit of that mystery but it
never quite it never quite gets to the
bombastic it's possibly a little too
much levels of all the strange creatures
or I am the doctor
certainly there's something about the
build that as it just sort of works its
way up and again in this particular tre
it's you know that sort of jutsu
that is played throughout a numerous
tracks and in the soundtracks that came
out during Capaldi's run but there's
something about the transition into it
with this one which is similar to what I
said about Amy and the TARDIS
it starts easier it starts easier starts
lighter it starts more sort of where do
we go and then it starts kicking in and
it builds and I love the bill and I love
the strength of it and it doesn't feel
as mmm it just feels like yeah just
standing tall number two this is another
track that I talked about when I talked
about this episode I talked about the
music the impossible planet
[Music]
this music this is a singular piece of
work from Ari Gold as far as I'm
concerned because it sounds like nothing
else that was ever on the show and for
the episodes that it appears in it is
perfect the sense of loneliness the
sense of isolation the sense of
melancholy and this sound that is so
unlike Doctor Who what it sounds like
more than anything honestly it sounds
like a track from Firefly from one of
the more dour episodes of that and it it
just doesn't sound like Doctor Who but
it's perfect for this lonely planet
orbiting a black hole that shouldn't be
there and people who should not be on it
but are and just what are we doing here
and it's not just the track it's the
points at which it's used because like
there's moments like when Tobey is out
on the planet's surface which should be
a death sentence and he turns and he's
got you know and he he gets spotted out
there by a crew mate and that normally
would be like a dungeon tanta kind of
thing presents just this quiet music you
shouldn't be out there what's going on
it's so effective and it enhances an
already brilliant episode brilliant
two-parter man like part of me wants to
say I wish there was more music like
this in the show but somehow it works
just existing for this and my personal
pick for the number one best track the
Murray gold composed for Doctor Who the
greatest story never told
[Music]
this track was for another two part of
that I absolutely loved which is the
silence in the library force of the Dead
two parters it's the introduction of
River Song story and I all of these are
great in Episode I personally think all
of these are worth listening to in
isolation what I love about this track
specifically besides just being great
music for reasons that I've talked about
almost everything else on this list for
the the way it builds the triumph of it
the way it weaves in themes that we've
heard before and gives us a you know a
new sense a new meaning behind them and
things like that but this track it it's
not about any one moment in it it's
about the whole thing because I feel
like this track tells a complete story
it's like Peter and the wolf it's got
that kind of progression as it moves
along and you can feel every dip in the
story and this sense of God that were
it's falling apart to know we know what
we can do into a sense of triumph at the
end and it really does and just I don't
know what it is five six minutes feels
like it delivers a complete story in
music form only even without the visuals
you add it to of the visuals and
everything becomes all the better
this track is everything if somebody
were asked me what is Doctor Who music
like I would give them this track to
listen to and I'd say that that right
there that is not only Doctor Who music
that is Doctor Who that is modern Doctor
Who in a nutshell in one track I love it
so those are my picks for the ten best
tracks that Murray gold ever composed
for Doctor Who I have no idea what the
response to this video is going to be
like or what people's thoughts are gonna
be I will be really curious to hear so
what are your thoughts on the list that
I gave what tracks would you put on your
own personal top ten list whatever your
thoughts are stop laying down in the
comments let's talk about it there's all
stuff for you to do support me on
patreon and like and subscribe and
Twitter podcast blah blah blah blah blah
links for all that stuff is down in the
description of course so until next time
this council is adjourned
[Music]